Fabi first of all I want to bring to you
a statistic you've never beaten nepo in
a classical game were you aware of that
shocked I didn't think about it but it's
it's not surprising we we drew a lot of
games that he beat me in subrep in 2019
and I think those were all we drew four
games in candidates I think yeah he beat
me I mean Instagram I was like
completely winning I I just I suicided
um
with five pieces I was winning I just
collapsed for no reason and yeah the
wrestler draws a lot of fighting draws
like the candidates were really sharp to
two sharp throws your initial feelings
after uh this grinding Victory okay I
had nothing out of the opening I mean
well I I thought he kind of got careless
a little bit and then I got careless
like Bishop C7 allows Knight A4 I mean
before Bishop z7 is equal but then he
allows Knight A4 and right after I
played 92 I was like why didn't I play
Knight A4 and I have a very pleasant
position
um
and okay then it was equal again like
for a long time we were just playing
instantly and nothing was happening
were you harboring any hopes at this
point like who was playing for a victory
were you guys just trying to like find a
repetition what was uh basically if you
played pg8 here I was actually I was
actually going to play King G1 I didn't
see then he so this was the repetition
yeah I didn't really see like what to do
um but then he put his King on
on E7
and I don't know why but it made me like
it doesn't change anything but it made
me like a little bit more optimistic and
then I saw this nice C2 maneuver and I
was like oh okay like my Queen's getting
in I mean that obviously changes nothing
the position is equal no matter what uh
even if my queen is in but if I get
Queen E5 Knight D4 then
it looks a little bit more more pleasant
for white and then you play this move
Knight to E4 yeah I was happy because I
could never risk this position I mean
it's of course a draw yeah but if I
don't trade Queens then I I need
absolutely never risk okay trading
Queens can get dangerous because my
queen side is vulnerable
and
yeah then when he played here I actually
saw this line up to Queen C2 and I
played Queen E2 because I thought Queen
C3 is Supernatural
at this point I thought It's
Supernatural and I basically saw that
here he's he's sort of
um like it's very normal what he's doing
yeah it always looks very logical and I
saw his position and it looked like I'm
making progress although I thought
first I thought that Queen C5 was a draw
based on this and then I saw this very
nice Queen H7 because if I trade queens
and I don't think I have any winning
Chances with Queen D4 or well for
example Queen D4 Queen D5 take take I
don't believe that this position I have
any winning chances because this king
gets in very quickly but I saw his Queen
Seven it looked very interesting
uh and then I thought he would play B5
and I kind of thought that it's a draw
somehow here but I I still thought it's
more pleasant for me uh here I was
already thinking like it is a kind of
borderline winning because
I mean I thought maybe it's a draw here
I didn't see like all the details I was
surprised by Queen A2 I thought Queen C2
but then I saw something here which made
me happy did you feel like he relaxed
prematurely I mean the position was
equal out of the opening it felt like it
was equal throughout the middle game and
then he started playing this dubious
moves especially at five yeah it was
well already he was gaining difficulties
so normally you shouldn't get into the
situation where so you were feeling the
pressure was getting to him at this
point I mean at this point he first of
all he looked unhappy after Queen C2 and
he has no like clear path to a draw I
mean it's probably a draw but he might
have to defend four against three with
queen and Knight against Queen Bishop
that's not very pleasant
um at least he has to like calculate
everything it's not an easy defensive
task I think yeah
and
yeah I was surprised by Queen A2 but
then he found this absolutely brilliant
resource can get jail I hadn't seen I
thought the game's over I was like
waiting more or less because if if he
takes uh okay I take both pawns and
that's what I want because then he can't
kill my knight anymore or he can pin it
but I can always break it after King
agent I was like uh first I thought
Queen C5 must be winning but then Bishop
B3 queen of 80 as Bishop G8 and I
thought maybe this is winning but I
couldn't quite see it and I was trying
all sorts of moves here like I literally
was thinking about every every possible
queen of like Queen C3 even Bishop C4
and King G1 for example it was like part
of my thought process yeah because
if my knight gets to D4 like and I win
the F5 Pawn then he just collapses like
let's say this type of position
um or here yeah what's the queen G8 the
queen of five I mean the problem is that
he's gonna lose
but I I saw something that bothered me
and then I spent like all my time and I
played this okay repeat it once I played
this thing which really worried me
because I'm pinned and
I saw like some G5 stuff but then I
thought like a G5 I take take and King
E1
and queen D2 and somehow I free myself
and I mean even up to the end I was like
very very confused with everything yeah
I mean here I was like okay but once you
got the Knight to D4 everything
seems secure right your hearing seems
secure you're not giving pain anymore
still with one minute I'm not like super
confident of course
and then Queen D3 I mean it's very
interesting try but I'm lucky I have a
picture of Queen C1
um
I mean also probably Knight C6 is
winning but yeah it's it's like you have
to kind of keep working for for it it's
winning but
you know with one minute anything can
happen but yeah once I saw his Queen see
when I was very happy because uh I win
the bishop Bobby back to back victories
uh with the white pieces you made the
best possible outcome whenever you have
the white pieces happen
um how do you feel about your
performance up to this point and what's
the strategy for tomorrow against a more
or less struggling player do that with
the black pieces okay this is a very
very important game it's it's really
satisfying uh also because uh I mean Jan
just played a world championship match
and I didn't achieve anything from the
opening but still I was out playing him
so so it's very satisfying
um still of course I mean the tournament
situation is good but the situation is
good but still early and yeah doodle
with black I I am quite tired so I do
want to
um to recover some energy before the
game tomorrow Bobby will let you go get
some energy and we'll see you tomorrow
it's back to you thank you Christian our
congratulations